-Elle aime faire de la politique
en chantant, en dansant,
et parfois même
en criant dans le métro.
Mon invitée a le sens du spectacle
et elle le met au service
de l'action collective.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Danielle Simonnet.
Alors, dans votre famille politique,
il y a le style Mélenchon,
qui est fait d'éloquence,
d'érudition et de discours,
et le style Danielle Simonnet,
plus terre-à-terre,
au contact
des gens,
avec un petit côté saltimbanque
de la politique,
comme on va le voir ici.
*-Bonjour, c'est le Front de gauche.
*-Jusque dans le métro parisien,
*le Front de gauche
mène campagne contre la loi
*sur l'emploi.
*-Il y en a parmi vous
qui vont au travail, ce matin ?
*Ca fait pas lourd !
Forcément, c'est la crise.
*On peut s'opposer à cette loi,
refusez que les députés l'adoptent.
-Ca, c'est une criée
dans le métro.
Vous avez inventé le concept,
on peut le dire.
Ca représente assez bien votre façon
de faire de la politique.
Je voulais commencer
en vous demandant
de définir votre façon
de faire de la politique.
-C'est de vouloir impliquer
le plus grand nombre pour que...
Si on souhaite changer
nos conditions de vie
et si on veut radicalement
changer la société,
il faut que le plus grand nombre
s'en mêle,
puisque aujourd'hui,
les politiques
sont souvent faites
par une petite poignée.
Nous critiquons beaucoup
la Ve République,
sa logique oligarchique.
On souhaite que le peuple
s'approprie son destin,
puisse écrire la Constitution
et que les lois cessent
d'être faites contre le peuple.
-Donc, c'est déclencher
une implication.
-Oui, une implication collective.
-Vous avez dit dans un article
que votre conception
de l'engagement,
c'était de mettre
vos tripes sur la table.
On le sent,
on le voit,
dans cette archive.
Cette façon de faire
peut aussi déranger et agacer.
Dans le métro,
vous rentrez de force dans la vie
des passagers en criant,
en essayant de les faire réagir.
Vous comprenez
que ça puisse un peu agacer ?
-En fait, à chaque fois,
j'ai des réactions
des citoyens, des citoyennes,
majoritairement contents,
parce qu'on se prend pas au sérieux
et on fait passer un message
extrêmement sérieux.
Cette façon de casser les codes...
C'est pas parce qu'on est élu,
qu'on a un mandat,
qu'on est au-dessus des autres.
On est attachés
à "liberté, égalité, fraternité".
Il faut, je pense,
assumer de casser les codes
pour permettre à tous
de se sentir légitimes
pour s'engager
dans la bataille politique.
-On ne va pas faire la liste
de vos happenings politiques,
mais vous avez fait défiler
un faux chameau à Paris Plages
pour dénoncer la fermeture de lits
à l'hôpital de l'Hôtel-Dieu.
Vous avez aussi mis en scène
des poulets géants plongeant
dans une piscine pour dénoncer
l'importation de poulets
au chlore américains.
-Le grand marché
transatlantique.
-Un accord de libre-échange.
-Aucun média n'en parlait.
On fait cette action,
cet happening,
on se marre beaucoup,
ça fait un vrai buzz,
et on obtient ce qu'on voulait,
c'est-à-dire un article
pleine page du Monde, qui va,
par cette entrée, aborder
sérieusement comme on voulait
les conséquences terribles
des accords de libre-échange.
-Vous avez répondu à ma question
avant que je la pose.
Il y a un côté drôle, amusant,
ça fait sourire, mais...
-C'est Mathilde Panot.
-Oui, Mathilde Panot,
on l'a reconnue.
Toute jeune sur les images.
Est-ce que c'est efficace,
ce n'est pas
de la politique spectacle ?
-On est dans une société
du spectacle
où on veut nous divertir,
ne pas faire en sorte
que les citoyens se préoccupent
de la politique en les divertissant.
Nous, on tord ça
et je fais l'inverse.
Par la mise en spectacle,
j'intéresse tout le monde
à un sujet extrêmement important.
Par une image, par l'humour,
par le décalage.
-Dans un registre différent,
vous avez monté
votre propre spectacle,
un seule en scène,
très personnel et politique.
Le titre, c'était
"Uber, les salauds et mes ovaires".
Ca répondait à quel besoin,
chez vous ?
-Le besoin d'abord
de raconter ce que j'avais
découvert en soutenant
de manière un peu accidentelle
la lutte des taxis.
Je réalisais à quel point
l'ubérisation était
un suicide social collectif
contre le Code du travail,
le système de protection social
et nos services publics
par le biais de l'évasion fiscale.
J'avais aussi envie de parler
de la bataille féministe
et à quel point c'était important,
quand on est une femme en politique,
d'assumer de mener ce combat-là.
-Pourquoi ce mode d'expression,
la scène ?
-En fait, la scène
libère complètement
et permet aussi de casser les codes.
Et puis, vous savez,
c'est pas tout le monde
qui va ouvrir la porte
pour aller à un meeting politique.
Par contre, à un spectacle,
vous invitez vos amis,
vos voisins, vos proches et donc,
le spectacle permet d'aborder
la question politique.
J'aime beaucoup cette démarche
d'éducation populaire.
-Quand on voit votre façon
de faire de la politique,
je fais le lien
avec votre environnement familial,
vos parents,
qui sont artistes, sculpteurs.
On les voit
sur ces images.
Vous assumez une forme
d'héritage familial ?
-Ah bah, bien sûr !
Je suis très fière...
-L'art est présent en vous.
-De façon différente.
Je suis très fière de mes parents.
-C'est vous, enfant.
-Oui, en train de sautiller
devant une grande chaise
de mes parents,
qui a été exposée d'ailleurs
au Grand Palais.
C'est vrai que mes parents ont
une vie professionnelle d'engagement
à travers l'engagement artistique,
d'assumer
de créer un langage,
de créer des formes, de créer
de l'art dans la rue,
pour que tout le monde puisse
se l'approprier et vivre avec.
Ils ont fait à la fois du jeu
et de la sculpture monumentale
et c'est vrai
que le fait d'assumer
ces transgressions
esthétiques, je pense
que ça m'a accompagnée.
Ils avaient aussi
des engagements militants
et on aimait beaucoup débattre.
On aime toujours débattre.
Cette éducation...
-Elle vous a influencée.
-Elle m'a construite.
-En me penchant sur votre histoire,
j'ai découvert
que vous étiez croyante,
catholique pratiquante
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans.
Vous vouliez même
devenir mère Teresa, c'est vrai ?
-Quand j'étais toute petite,
c'était vraiment...
L'injustice, ne pas supporter
que des enfants meurent de faim.
Je ne manquais de rien.
Je me suis rendu compte après
que mes parents
étaient fauchés,
au début de leur vie.
Ils disaient : "Ce qui est dur,
quand on est artiste,
"ce sont les 60 premières années
professionnelles."
Mais cette figure
où on s'engage toute sa vie
pour les autres
et contre l'injustice,
le fait que des enfants
meurent de faim, ça m'avait marquée.
-Cette éducation catholique
vous a un peu forgée
ou a éveillé
votre conscience sociale ?
-Je pense que cette exigence
d'engagement pour autrui
m'a marquée,
même si...
Mes parents
avaient des contradictions,
on allait à la messe
et quand on rentrait à la maison,
c'était Léo Ferré
avec "Ni Dieu ni maître".
Après, j'ai gardé
le "Ni Dieu ni maître",
mais j'ai du respect
pour les spiritualités.
Je suis laïque et attachée
à la liberté de conscience,
mais je garde de cette éducation
la nécessité de la solidarité,
de prendre conscience
de notre interdépendance.
-Au collège,
vous vous engagez dans la lutte
contre le racisme et au lycée,
vous avez mis
votre lycée en grève
contre la loi Devaquet.
Vous dites :
"J'ai découvert le pouvoir
de l'action collective."
On revient à ça.
Quand vous avez réalisé cela,
ce n'est pas ce qui a déterminé
tout le reste
de l'engagement ?
-Si vous participez à la grève,
à des manifestations,
et que vous n'êtes pas isolé
dans votre lycée
de la Seine-et-Marne,
vous réalisez que dans les médias,
ce mouvement va changer
le cours de l'histoire,
il va faire tomber
un gouvernement
et nous allons gagner.
Je prends conscience de cela
et je souhaite aller à l'université
pour m'engager pleinement.
Je veux faire de ma vie
un engagement politique
et participer à changer
le cours de l'histoire.
-C'est là que vous rejoignez
le syndicat de l'Unef
et que vous vous mobilisez
contre le CIP, le Contrat
d'insertion professionnelle.
C'était en 1994.
*Ils chantent.
*-AVEZ-VOUS VU PASSER
LE DEFUNT CIP ?
*-Depuis le début, ici, à Créteil,
Danielle écrit les chansons.
*-C'est des chansons spécifiques
pour la manifestation, pour dire
*qu'on a gagné.
On voulait pas nous écouter,
on est venus dans la rue
pendant un mois.
*On a fait grève, on a gagné.
-Quelle surprise !
Vous écriviez les chansons.
-J'ai jamais revu ces images.
Oh, c'est génial.
-Vous écriviez déjà les chansons.
-C'est important, la joie.
-Et l'énergie, d'où votre surnom,
"Danette la mitraillette".
On comprend pourquoi.
L'Unef vous a amenée
au Parti socialiste,
c'était la pouponnière du PS,
à l'époque.
Au PS, au moment
de la guerre du Golfe,
vous vous rapprochez
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
En 2000,
vous rejoignez son cabinet
au ministère de l'Enseignement.
Vous dites que la politique
façon techno, c'est pas votre truc.
Vous avez été heureuse au cabinet ?
-C'était une expérience
extrêmement enrichissante,
mais dure, en même temps.
C'est important de comprendre
comment ça se passe,
mais c'était pas évident.
-On vous voit très sérieuse
sur le perron du ministère.
-J'étais conseillère
d'orientation-psychologue.
J'avais un an
d'exercice professionnel
et je me retrouve dans le cabinet
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pour travailler
les questions d'orientation.
C'est très difficile,
mais en même temps,
c'est fondamental.
A un moment, il va falloir
désacraliser les institutions
et se dire que notre objectif,
c'est la prise du pouvoir
pour pouvoir instaurer
une autre politique.
-Vous avez suivi Jean-Luc Mélenchon
au Parti de gauche.
Vous vous êtes battue
pour les pauvres,
en occupant un logement
de la Ville de Paris
avec un loyer qui était
sous les prix du marché.
Vous étiez pas
en situation illégale,
mais vos adversaires
vous ont reproché
un manque d'exemplarité
sur ce sujet-là.
Pourquoi avoir attendu
d'être députée
pour rendre ce logement ?
-Autour de moi,
dans le 20e, on me disait rien.
J'y étais avec les droits.
Avec mes revenus,
je ne serais pas élue,
j'y aurais droit,
il n'y avait aucun abus.
-C'était pas un HLM sous conditions
de ressources, mais le loyer...
-Le premier jour
où j'entre dans ce logement,
il est pas en dessous du marché
à ce moment-là, en 2003.
-Pourquoi l'avoir rendu
en devenant députée ?
-J'ai pas envie que ça revienne.
Les médias veulent attaquer LFI.
Et les revenus des députés
sont différents.
Je déménage. Enfin, j'ai déménagé.
-On va conclure
par notre quiz, à présent.
Le principe est assez simple.
Je commence une phrase
et vous allez la compléter.
On y va ?
"Avant d'être députée,
"je pensais que l'Assemblée..."
-Ce serait très difficile
de pouvoir s'exprimer
dans une plénière aussi intimidante.
-"Le meilleur happening
à l'Assemblée serait..."
-Le fait qu'on ait chanté
La Marseillaise au moment du 49.3
en brandissant
nos pancartes "démocratie",
"retrait du texte de loi",
est extrêmement important.
J'ai pas eu l'idée,
mais je la trouve excellente,
car il est important
de rappeler d'où on vient,
de la Révolution française.
Ce mépris démocratique
du 49.3 montre
qu'on a au moins
49,3 bonnes raisons
de vouloir une VIe République.
-"Quand quelqu'un me confond
"avec Marine Le Pen..."
J'ai lu dans un portrait
que ça vous arrivait,
dans la rue, parfois.
-Oui. En même temps,
il faut en rire.
Il y a eu des quiproquos,
des gens désagréables avec moi.
Dans le 20e arrondissement,
l'extrême droite est pas appréciée.
Oui, écoutez,
c'est la preuve
qu'il y a peu de femmes
en politique et qu'on va confondre
une blonde avec une autre.
Eh bien, non.
Je n'ai rien à voir
avec Marine Le Pen
et je suis très attachée
au partage des richesses,
à la bataille écologique,
à la VIe République
et à l'antiracisme.
-Ce sera le mot de la fin.
Merci beaucoup d'être venue.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...